[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
[Applause]
[Applause]
today is Monday September 19th and Joey
Diaz has officially begun his residency
Joey Diaz live on Broadway at Sony Hall
we also had Dave Chappelle surprise Joe
Rogan in front of a sold out Arena last
weekend so it's a pack show on the joke
World comedy update every single Monday
bringing you all the comedy news that
you need to know from your favorite
comedians your favorite podcasters
anything to do with comedy all in one
place so please consider subscribing to
joke world right now turning on the post
notifications and downloading this
episode on Spotify to support the show
Sony theater tickets are up
is up to you if you haven't been to New
York lately fly in take your wife to
dinner I don't know bring mom come visit
your [ __ ] grandchildren whatever I'm
not coming to you this year you're
coming to me so last weekend was the
start of Joey Diaz live on Broadway it's
a five-month residency taking place in
New York City for Joey Diaz apparently
for the first show Lee syat his old
producer from the church of what's
happening now he was there and he did a
set of stand up to open the show Ari
shafir stopped by and did some stand up
and also Stu finder was there to
introduce Joey to the crowd it was a
smashing success I mean beyond your
wildest dreams like your worst critic
will give you an A and less credit we'll
give you an A plus plus because it was
really and it showed how hard you worked
you said you've been practicing for
three months because the quality and the
length of the material was phenomenal I
mean you told like 20 amazing Stories
you bought the house down besides you
having a vagina you couldn't have
attracted more energy from a crowd I
love you
we're here to stay
extra exciting comedy fans because there
was a little bit there where Joey Diaz
was fully retired from stand up when he
moved from La back to New Jersey he said
he was done getting on stage he was just
focusing on his podcast writing a book
raising his kid then he kind of came out
of retirement to join bird on the fully
loaded tour apparently it did take some
convincing but he must have gotten the
bug back for it or realize that he's
still amazing at it because his
residency is five months long and I feel
like if it goes well we'll probably have
Joey Diaz back in our grasp doing stand
up for good full-time
Dave Chappelle surprised a very lucky 19
000 people in Columbus Ohio last weekend
when he dropped into Joe Rogan's sold
out arena show Hans Kim opened the show
followed by Tony Hinchcliffe and Tony's
actually from Youngstown Ohio Dave
Chappelle lives in Dayton about an hour
away from Columbus so this is home to
both these guys it was a really cool
moment when Tony brought up Dave
Chappelle because like I said it was a
surprise so these 19 000 people in the
sold out Arena who think they're already
going to see Joe Rogan now they get to
see Dave Chappelle
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
there was also some really dope pictures
of Chappelle and Rogan sharing the stage
which I mean imagine if you were just
one of those people that were there and
you get to see two of not even debatably
the most influential comedians of Our
Generation on stage together must have
been a night to remember in Columbus Joe
koi has a new special out on Netflix
right now titled Joe Coy live from the
LA Forum according to the description
Joe gushes about his relationship with
his teenage son along with sharing the
struggles of living with sleep apnea and
much much more
hey guys gotta take a quick break from
this week's comedy news to hear a word
from our friends at the freeze pipe
listen guys if you've been smoking for a
while it's time to upgrade that
experience and the only way to do that
is with the freeze pipe whether it's
their Frozen hand Cannon or one of their
big recycler bongs the freeze pipe Just
Hits different and that's because
they're built different literally unlike
any other bong in the world the freeze
pipe uses glycerin a non-toxic gel that
freezes quicker than water and stays
Frozen much longer the glycerin Chambers
are designed to help improve how much
and how long your smoke is chilled for
so basically what that means is you put
this [ __ ] in the freezer for an hour you
take it out of the freezer you put it
back into the bong you light on fire and
When the Smoke comes up this tube it's
filtered through the glycerin the Frozen
Chambers to deliver the iciest smoothest
hit you'll ever take in your whole life
no matter what you're into or what your
budget there's something for everyone on
the freeze pipe.com literally cleaning
supplies keychain Grinders it doesn't
matter shipping is always free and
always discreet plus you get 10 off
using our code joke 10. so if you want
to have a better quality of life and
support the channel go check out
thefreeze pipe.com and use code joke 10
for 10 off your order get from last week
your mom's house talked to Sam Morrell
two bears one cave was Burton Tom Tom
and Bert tiger belly had on Rick
Glassman Lee sayat was on Uncle Joey's
joint so a reunion for Joey and Lee and
probably the episode of the week whiskey
Ginger had on Mark Norman I saw a guy
the other day on in SoHo it should have
said listen to black women a white guy
and I'm like who isn't listening is
there people walking by black women like
what are you doing would you just be a
good person is that a terrorist walking
Listen to Black women and what's funny
is because you kind of want to talk to
him and go what do you saying what are
you saying by that like who do you yeah
what do you mean by this right and what
if they're saying something duh I don't
get it it's so it's such an absolute
it's such a broad statement right right
like like Mike like like Mark Normand
right almost impossible it's um I'm the
worst are you garbage out on Joe Coy
flagrant also had on Joe Coy promoting
the special kill Tony tonight is an
interesting group it's Ron White Ryan
long and Brian Simpson that bad friends
talk to Ali McCoskey today and this past
weekend was with Bert crischler you
don't want to go too corporate of a
studio where it feels like where it
doesn't feel like Rogue you know like
yeah and you also don't want to do it
out of your house which I've been doing
for the past [ __ ] eight years and so
people are like do you live here okay is
that your daughter can I meet her and
you're like Georgia grab a towel yeah
she's doing this audio for us right now
but as soon as she's like I want to get
bigger guess you know who I want to get
I'm being dead serious we talked about
this a little bit and I think you're the
only person who'll get this let me guess
who it is oh if you guess it if you
guessed it I'll spend the rest of the
show with my flip-flop in my mouth oh
dude that's gonna mess up the chat
but I'll try let me see it's uh can I
ask for a clue or not yes okay
is it a black
person no
there are a couple that I'd like to get
on I'd like to get on uh I like Killer
Mike on I like Killer Mike I like Snoop
on
um I Like Big Boy from Outcast I'd Like
T.I I should give a shout out to TI
about his car keep saying stuff you're
just eliminating guests I was gonna
guess
oh yeah that's right so you're going
with the well you going with the white
dude I'm going with a white dude I think
he's white I don't even know his name to
be honest with you it's hot in here guys
can y'all cut that AC on
um I drank a lot yesterday and I woke up
in the middle of the night in a [ __ ]
Sizzle I mean I was so hot and all of a
sudden my body went
and [ __ ] poured sweat back to sleep
yeah yeah like almost like when a truck
stops and it's like
new comedy specials from last week we
had a full hour from Hernan hurstburg
called jokes from the underground and
that's out on YouTube right now hey
yeah we're here we're doing it we're
back we might be drunk
ah good to have fun how the hell are you
you got a buddy run on hershberg with us
he's got a new special out on YouTube
what's the name of the special I joke
from the underground uh I was there it
was great great special watch this
special it's good to see you man thanks
for having me yeah it's great to be here
um yeah it's nice I'm gonna if you want
me to relapse on the show I can really
really would you do that
alcoholic beer and then we already
talked about it a few times but Joe Coy
has a new stand-up special on Netflix
called Joe Coy live from the LA forum
that's it for specials this week and
that's it for the joke World comedy
update number 17. thank you so much for
watching please make sure to subscribe
to joke world if you haven't follow us
on Instagram if you haven't download
this episode on Spotify if you haven't I
don't know what else you guys haven't
done but those are the three main things
maybe a fourth would be subscribed to
the second Channel clip world but that's
really not that necessary just thanks
for getting the end of this video means
a lot
maybe pick one of the the videos from
the outro you could do that too that'd
be like a fifth thing if you haven't
done that
all right that's it for me see you guys
next Monday
foreign
[Music]